olá pessoal hoje trago de que este
pequeno vídeo porque eu tenho uma coisa
pra dizer não acho não sei como é que de
dizer isto é o vídeo não vai roubar
corte não vai roubar nada que sue x
estava em 8 bits em um distrito muito
com a minha vida
neste momento não está a ser assim não é
ontem o teto uma conversa com a treinar
nos jogos e em nós dois pensamos que
este seria o melhor tanto para mim como
para ela então é difícil imagina
vai ter que ser assim não está a ser tão
bom como era e eu adoro adoro tudo
aquilo que você tem feito por mim mas
não é suficiente não já não é mais
então nós resolvemos kan não pode ficar
assim com mais um elemento
então eu resolvi eu vou criar um canal
do boxe postar um vídeo por de e mestre
canal está na descrição por isso tudo
está em casa com um vídeo por dia mais
um canal fox já não tem desculpa para
não ver os meus pedro peixoto líquida
choque favorito deixe um comentário e
partilha com os seus amigos mesmo que
eles não sejam menos 2016 vai ser o
nosso - que o nosso ano foi na bunda ia
te